[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه استشهاد احد عشر فلسطينيا
واصابه اكثر من مئه اخرين حالات بعضهم
خطيره خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال مدينه
نابلس الشماليه الضفه الغربيه بذريعه وجود
مطلوبين وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قواته
قامت بتصفيه اعضاء في حركه الجهاد وعارين
الاسود متورطين في اطلاق النار على قواته
حسب زعمه واعلنت سرايا القدس استشهاد قائد
كتيبه نابلس محمد ابو بكر جنيدي خلال
المواجهات من جهتها حذرت كتائب القسام في
غزه من ان صبرها اخذ في النفاذ
وطالبت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الاداره
الامريكيه بالتحرك فورا وقال المندوب
الفلسطيني لدى الامم المتحده انه نقل الى
الامين العام للامم المتحده تفاصيل مجزره
نابلس وابلغه بمطالب الشعب الفلسطيني
المتمثله في توفير الحمايه الدوليه
من جهته اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قلق بلاده من ان يؤدي الهجوم
على نابلس الى تراجع جهود اعاده الاستقرار
قال رضا بالحاج القيادي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطني المعارضه في تونس ان قوات امنيه
اقتحمت منزل عصام الشاب الامين العام
للحزب الجمهوري المعارض واعتقلت كما افادت
مصادر حقوقيه تونسيه باعتقال القياديه في
جبهه الخلاص المعارضه شيماء عيسى وقد اعرب
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلاقه حيال التطورات
في تونس وقال في بيان ان البلاد بحاجه الى
حلول لتحديات الحاليه والمستقبليه
وقال الرئيس قيس سعيد ان هناك حملات وصفها
بالمسعوره من اشخاص قال انهم ماجورون من
الخارج لضرب الدوله التونسيه على حد
تعبيره
اجتمع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
العاصمه البولنديه وارسو بقياده الدول
الاعضاء في النيتو شرقي اوروبا وقال بايدن
النحلف شمال الاطلسي قام بعمل مهم لفتره
طويله من الزمن وانه من المهم ان يبقى
الحلف متحدا للتصدي لاي عدوان قادم
في المقابل قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه مارايز خروفه ان عدم تطرق
المسؤولين الامريكيين الى الرغبه بالتسويه
السياسيه دليل على نيه واشنطن زياده
التصعيد ورحب زخرفه باستعداد الصين لاعب
دور في تسويه الازمه
وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه بعد
لقائه الرئيس الروسي في موسكو النبيجين
ستقوم بدور محايد وموضوعين وبناء بين
روسيا واوكرانيا
اكد رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي رفض بلاده لما وصفه بالضغوط
السياسيه التي تسعى الى اجبارها على تنفيذ
الالتزامات النوويه من طرف واحد ونفى
اسلامي ما وصفه بالاتهامات الباطله لبلاده
بشان كشف يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 84%
من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني طهران
مستعده لاتمام مباحثه فيينا واكد استعداد
بلاده للمضي في مسار غير المفاوضات اذا ما
قرر الطرف الامريكي ذلك هذا وقلت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان ملف اعاده احياء الاتفاق
النووي لا يزال خارج اجندتها
كتاب الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]